merci au revoir
pardon je rigole quand tu m'appelles
abraham en scène c'est tismée métis en
verlan
vous n'avez pas de monde ça ne vous
trouve non c'est pas grave je vais quand
même vous présenter mon petit guide des
choses simples qui permettent de
stimuler la créativité c'est pas parce
que vous avez pas de nom de scène que
vous n'êtes pas des artistes pour moi on
est tous des artistes à des niveaux
différents et on a tous besoin à un
moment de créer ou d'être inspiré quel
que soit notre occupation
moi je suis rappeurs chanteurs slameurs
auteur compositeur beatboxer metteur en
scène dj batteur ingestion amzer
organisateurs de soirées et d'événements
souvent on me dit que ça fait beaucoup
que je me disperse forcément je dis bah
oui je me disperse je fais en sorte que
la dispersion reste positive
un problème de mesure culture un autre
et ainsi de suite
et puis tu façon j'aime faire plein de
choses c'est comme ça j'en ai besoin
par contre j'ai besoin de trouver assez
tôt comment bien organisée m'imposer une
grande rigueur trouver comment être
efficace dans le processus de création
ça n'a pas été facile
donc aujourd'hui je vous présentais 5,5
idées toutes simples qui permettent de
booster la créativité de la favoriser
voilà c'est des choses que j'ai
découverte voilà et et je me dis que ça
peut être pourrais peut-être vous servir
aussi tout simplement première idée le
matin
le matin est le premier secret qui me
permet d'être productif inspiré et
créatif j'adore me lever avant 7 heures
je trouve que se lever tôt c'est comme
observé sa journée du haut d'une
montagne on peut mieux la préparer et du
coup mieux la vivre ensuite quand
j'étais petit ma mère me parlait des
idées du matin elle me disait que les
toutes premières idées qui viennent de
notre tête le matin quand on se réveille
en particulier taux bas qu'il fallait
les écouter faire attention à elle
maintenant même quand je me réveille
plus tard et que j'ai pas ce petit
rituel est bien je me sens un peu perdue
j'ai l'impression de passer à côté de ma
journée d'avoir raté un train qui passe
qu'une seule fois par jour le matin j'ai
des idées si clair qu'elles deviennent
aussitôt foncé l'inspiration est une
mère et je suis loin d'y revoir pied est
ce que vous pouvez faire juste un petit
truc très simple vu sa très jolie pas
trop vite ce qui arrive pas à le faire
fait semblant ce pas un peu moins vite
un peu moins vite
voilà il faut que ça groove un petit peu
que ça souligne un peu ok il n'est que
six heures et pourtant toute ma journée
se joue maintenant maintes et maintes
fois j'ai tenté de frôler cet état mais
l'esprit a ses raisons que la raison ne
soupçonne pas pris entre les veillées le
rêve je croit distinguer mon destin en
pointillés semble dessiner me poussant a
tout testé à ne pas sous-estimer
on arrive on veut quand on s'y met
qu'importe s'ils nous nous ces corps sur
le ciment
car chaque jour on se relève plus grands
gravissant les marches à notre rythme
chacun sa voix sa doute ces défaites et
ses rythmes et qui ne cherchent pas à
décoller ses pieds du sol avec toutes
ces corvées qui nous retiennent par le
col un fond sonore un peu dans une
poignée d'idées et je décolle j'aperçois
l'inspiration la perse et mon flow
découlent les niçois ces matinées ou
mobile semble patiner
à ce refrain meriem semblait destiner le
dépôt de ma pensée se fait-elle un geste
ine béni soit ces matinées ou mon bic
semble patiner automne cette matinée
matinée ma fine matinée aura comblé ce
nouveau journée
la solitude la solitude n'est plus
vraiment à la mode aujourd'hui je parle
de la belle solitude 7 qui nous permet
de nous recentrer de réfléchir de savoir
où on en est d'écouter nos procès
intérieur qu'elles sont nous envie
profonde
j'ai l'impression qu'aujourd'hui c'est
pas vraiment la priorité
on n'a pas le temps on n'a plus le temps
soit disant les smartphones les réseaux
sociaux nous empêche d'avoir ces moments
de belles solitude on est seul mais
virtuellement avec quelqu'un les séries
les sites internet la télé nous donne
tout le temps l'impression d'avoir
quelque chose à faire enfin regardez en
fait et puis aussi ceux qui ont du mal à
se retrouver face à eux mêmes ce qui est
compréhensible parce que c'est pas
facile j'ai un petit texte à dessus
aussi mais je sais plus ce que ça fait
excusez moi seul sur la foule je perds
pas la boule qui me saoule trop il foule
trop seul tout est cool tu t'écoutes tu
te fous de la foutaise et tout est et
tout reste à ton aise c'est ton destin
pas le leur c'est ton festin il est
l'heure que tu te fasses fasse que tu te
fasses place temps quoique les heures
passent se tasse et aspire dans la masse
docile facile passive et naïve et hâtive
active ont noué rendons le new fort avec
des jeux forts de la mort ces dames sont
c'est l'âme soeur de nouveaux horizons
pensons-y quelques heures en restant
seul je fais pas ce qu'on dit seul mon
âme bondi seuls les marches gravies seul
un spi brandi un ma solitude brandi un
seul jeu resplendit seul toi qu'est ce
t'en dis oui ce qui est bien aussi c'est
que seul on est libre on fait vraiment
ce qu'on veut on peut aller dans nos
délires notre folie on peut être sincère
avec nous mêmes du coup je me dis que
pour être sincère avec les autres ça
vaut peut-être le coup d'être un peu
sincère avec nous mêmes d'abord à des
moments
le respect de l'idée l'inspiration vient
en créant ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que ça tient souvent à une
décision toute simple celle de s'y
mettre
donc je vous fais une petite mise en
situation toute simple je viens de me
réveiller
alors j'ai pas de chapeau quand je me
réveille d'habitude enfin c'est pas ça
non plus mais c'est pas je viens de me
réveiller
il est 6 heures je suis seul
une idée me vient une mélodie en fait
d'un de bon là j'ai deux possibilités
soit je m'enregistre soit je vais manger
parce que j'ai très faim
enregistrée j'ai très faim
je sais pas si du coup je sais ce que
c'est que si je n'enregistre à risque de
prendre
bon je l'enregistré
j'ai vu
oh
et où métro métro boulot dodo
mais en prenant un cliché par jour ont
paré voir le même sur la photo les mêmes
têtes situation même 400 mutation même
fait même cède même
merci
j'avais pas fait le choix donc d'aller
enregistrer cette idée et ben j'aurais
pas créé ce morceau l'inspiration ce
travail se cultive quand on a une idée
surtout quand elle nous semble
importante
bah c'est justement important de
l'écrire de l'enregistrer de ce film est
de téléphoner à quelqu'un positif et
j'ai une idée je sais pas
la peindre et à sculpter on est dans
notre douche c'est un moment qui nous
appartient on est bien on est tranquille
on se détend ce magnifique et là on a
une idée et cette idée semble incroyable
ce sera sûrement la meilleure de notre
semaine on se dit bon alors évidemment
on n'a rien pour écrire dans le coin
du coup on se dit alors si je reste dans
ma douche comme ça exact en jeu risque
de la perdre si si je sors de la douche
pour aller dans ma chambre pour l'écrire
je vais tromper tout partout du coup il
faudrait que je sorte que je me sèche
mais quand je me sèche ça prend du temps
donc du coup peut-être que je vais
perdre l'idée et si je perds pas l'idée
est que j'arrive dans ma chambre et que
je décris est ce que ça vaut le coup que
je revienne dans ma bouche bref c'est
vraiment très compliqué comme situation
vraiment moi ma méthode c'est de se
répéter l'idée sans arrêt sans arrêt
sans arrêt même à haute voix son fou
après tout jusqu'à ce que je sorte de la
salle de bains le seul souci c'est que
ça m'empêche d'en avoir une autre
donc du coup je sais pas si c'est
vraiment la bonne méthode
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
plus on respecte l'inspiration et nos
petites idées nos grandes idées plus on
est inspirée affronter ses peurs ses
doutes quand on a une idée
que ça soit pour un projet proposition à
faire à quelqu'un le thème d'un morceau
il arrive souvent qu'on pense à la
version où on sera tous nuls ou c'est
pourri où ça plaît à personne
voilà pour vous donner un exemple
concret il ya deux semaines je pense à
mon intervention ici et je me dis mais
pourquoi se désintéresserait en fait et
si je bafouille et si j'oublie mon texte
ici à aucune mélodie qui me vient alors
de la mise en situation du poing droit
le respect des idées on est en plein
dans le doute dans la peur de l'inconnu
de l'échec ça peut paraître très basique
et c'est plus facile à dire qu'à faire
mais il faut combattre cette pensée se
voir grand et fort on est notre propre
limite et cette limite commence ici dès
le départ dans notre tête
qui va croire en notre idée si on n'a
pas convaincu pour se sous-estimer on
est très bons pour douter on est fort et
puis c'est tellement confortable de pas
prendre de risques mais ça fait
tellement du bien aussi de prendre des
risques c'est tellement enrichissant
donc pour la mise en situation du point
4 affronter ses peurs ses doutes
vous allez être effrayé à l'idée de
faire du beatbox faire du beatbox alors
fait très simple on va couper la salle
en deux vous inquiétez pas on va pas
vraiment le faire parce que sinon
monsieur vous êtes mal barré on va vous
choisissez un choisissant à côté c'est
bien en plus y'a le siège d'à côté qui
est libre donc vous pouvez choisir
tranquillement
donc on coupe la salle en deux de ce
côté là toute cette partie là même en
eau à toute cette partie là vous allez
être les poum les poules alors vous
explique c'est très simple prenez le
pommeau de pommes de terre vous enlever
le haut vous mettez vous à la place et
voilà vous sa dépouille
c'est magnifique alors ce qu'il faut
faire c'est bien bien l'envoyer bien
dynamisé la chose d'accord n'hésitez pas
à poster au nez c'est pas grave y'a pas
de problème
le voisin de devant comprendre même s'il
a un petit peu mouillée à la fin c'est
pas grave c'est très bien d'accord et
vous ne faites vous plaisir alors à
l'aller 8 euros
voilà donc les poum d'accord ici de ce
côté là vous allez imiter le bruit d'une
flèche qui rentrent dans un arbre je
sais c'est pas facile
non mais attendez attendez attendez
attendez on va dire on va dire que ça
fait à peu près de chaque chaque voilà
d'accord
normalement c'est plus facile à faire
que poum donc voilà ok donc on
récapitule vous êtes les poum vous êtes
et chaque vous êtes les poum l'athlète
chaque vous êtes les poules vous êtes
leccia
incroyable clermont c'est impressionnant
vous savez affronter vos peurs vous ça
va bravo alors cinquième point dernière
ne pas subir agir dans disait beach and
i want to see in the world
c'est à dire soyez le changement que
vous voulez voir dans le monde ne pas
attendre que l'exemple vienne de
quelqu'un d'autre devenir cet exemple ne
pas attendre d'être rassurés nous
défauts nos différences font ce que nous
sommes et ya pas une seule personne sur
cette terre qui n'a pas quelque chose à
accomplir ne pas subir agir en france on
aime bien se plaindre on aime beaucoup
se plaindre mais quand il faut agir
bon c'est peut-être parce qu'on a peur
aussi
ou c'est peut-être parce qu'on se lève
pas assez tôt du coup on n'a pas le
temps d'agir en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il vaut mieux agir que se
plaindre j'espère que vous êtes d'accord
avec moi
moi j'aime bien me plains dans les
chansons et une chanson je me plains que
j'aime bien que je pense que je vais
vous faire pour finir en plus elle parle
des gens donc vous la faire
oh oh oh oh oh d day
où les gens se prennent jamais la pâte
ont la patience passif hâte que ça les
gens se battent mais jamais ne se tâte
pour voir ce qu'il y a en de ça
les gens restent à la surface bien
certain que rien ne surpasse les gens
s'efface quand ils se font face trop
inquiet qu'on les surclasse les gens les
gens les gens les gens les gens les gens
leurs jambes à leur cou les gens ont
l'air fou genre tombé dans le flou
les gens se vante d'être gentil se voit
comme des gants dit même quand ils sont
en dit tout on en dit tout sur les gens
disent temps tels des anges quand je
pense que les gens c'est nous vient
envie de me taire sur les gens mais vers
doucement je perds on a beau dire mais
les ovales coup je parle des gens tu
parles des gens ils parlent des gens
mais les gens c'est nous nous parlons
des gens vous parler des gens elle parle
des gens mais les gens c'est nous je tu
ils nous vous ne s'avoue pas que les
gens c'est nous les laissons dire du mal
de nous les gens à propos des gens
geignent il serait temps qu'on daigne
faire les pas pour panser nos plaies qui
saigne